sorry is it Lachlan or Lachlan Lachlan
you're British I just wanted to check
all right all right all these [__]
Americans
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste I'm your host for today
guards joining me once again are the
boys and we are back in the Australia
studio with another Aussie guest do you
want to introduce yourself to the
audience yeah what's up guys it's
Lachlan here and uh yeah Keen to chat
with uh the boys today hell yeah man oh
yeah so for our audience who might not
be familiar with your content you want
to do a brief like introduction about
what you do yeah or you're doing YouTube
and you kind of like yeah enough for
sure so been making YouTube content for
10 years now yeah
um mainly doing gaming stuff free
summary started off doing Minecraft uh
actually first started because I really
like Pokemon and there was a mod that
brought Pokemon to Minecraft so did that
it's called Pixelmon did that for about
a couple years then moved to just
traditional Minecraft right and then did
Pokemon go for a while and then fortnite
for the last five years right so yeah oh
yeah so now that we've got our first
actual fortnite Creator on the first
yeah yeah yeah you you are the first
none of us like
and it's like every podcast has that
Meme did they actually say that on the
podcast or was that just the caption
underneath I think it actually is the
yeah I think that's the original captain
and they just got memes like it's just
how serious they're like yeah yeah
they're like damn is it though like [__]
let's discuss it
um look I mean ah kind of back in the
day I think it was properly rated now
I'd say maybe a bit overrated yeah right
right serious which I think we are I
think a lot of our audience isn't really
familiar with fortnite in general yeah
um is there kind of a way you can
encapsulate how you fortnite worked or
kind of had relation to your content and
how what your relationship to fortnite
was nah so it's like back when I first
started the fortnite kind of thing we've
just come off Pokemon go hype and did
you guys get around Pokemon go oh yeah
like
um uh so
um I played Pokemon go yeah but I didn't
have everything I didn't have a phone
that could run Pokemon go at the top
when did Pokemon go come out 2016
yeah yeah yeah yeah how old was I then
no I know you're like 12.
12. no I wait no I I had a yeah okay for
some reason I couldn't play it but I
felt really left out because everyone
everyone was playing yeah yeah I was
like why'd you play it on my PC
you've oh [__] you nah
okay so then you know because I was I I
felt so left out that I wanted to play
and it seemed fun because you know
because you were doing the spoofing
thing so yeah I did the spoon
you know I was farming and I got I was
like damn this shit's [__] boring
because I'm like walking around yeah no
[__] I was like where do I I was like
also at the time I was living in Wales
right right which is yeah which the
thing that I realized really quickly
about Pokemon go is that if you don't
live in a place that has stuff yeah
Pokemon go doesn't have a lot to offer
yeah yeah there was pretty much like two
things within like like 10 miles of
where I lived yeah I was like this is
[__] and so then I went I spoofed on the
map I clicked London I walked two feet
and I'd gone over ten poker stops and I
was like this is [__] privilege once
again so anyway I got banned pretty
quickly yeah okay I was teleporting oh
okay I was going like India all right
I'm gonna go to Japan get the Japan
exclusive Pokemon all right I'm going
back playing Pokemon go in Japan was
like [__] happy I bet it was because
it didn't come out until Monday I don't
know why Australia got it first yeah
Australia
yeah and I'm like what how does that
make sense we made it yeah well it's
it's like the Mario movie come not not
coming out of Japan yet right that's
right no it's not it's not out in Japan
yet actually it's out it's coming out
tomorrow yeah yeah
so for some reason when Japan like has
an IP that's Global now we get it last
yeah for some reason detective Pikachu
came out first in Japan okay yeah and
I'm like okay yeah it'll just make up
your [__]
at that point yeah I kind of missed the
Pokemon go craze and I was like so salty
about it because I was living in
Thailand at the time yeah right and I
saw these YouTube videos about people
like going to parks and having these big
Pokemon go Meats I was that guy yeah
yeah yeah yeah I probably saw one of
your like early videos because I was
like I had like this big phase where I
was like oh God I wish that was me came
out in Thailand and I remember I was
like yes I'm gonna go out yeah walk to
all these poker stops I remember like
going to my first pokestop
um it was about like 35 degree weather
in like like 100 humidity and the next
stop was like a 20 minute walk
I start walking for about 10 minutes and
I'm like they're saying it man I can't
[__] do this will you look on one of
the first people to like I guess make
videos on Pokemon go because I I was
flicking through your channel everyone
was making videos yeah yeah but I was
looking through your channel and I saw
that you had a video from I think six
years ago which was like Pokemon go
let's play part one yeah it has like 20
million views or something yeah yeah so
that was because I was following the
kind of project that week's leading up
being like okay no this is gonna go
crazy surely Pokemon out there on the
phone
um and then it came out like on midnight
and I literally was like downloaded my
phone rang one of my mates up like out
in the suburbs I was like you gotta come
over right now get the camera we're
going outside of the middle of night
catch a [__] Charmander get here so
we were like running around catching
canopies at 2AM and that's that video
yeah yeah you literally like first two
hours filmed yeah and then you I
presumably went home and edited it and
got it up bang oh and then I remember
going to bed waking up I think my
average views per video Back Then were
like 100 200k like over a week
especially back then and then like that
video I remember I went to bed after
grinding probably like five six a.m hit
post woke up and it was like on a mill
Mill and a half and I was like oh yes
hey yo we talking I'm on to something
here yeah so part two was the next that
I woke up running back it was round two
let's go right now yeah no but it was
like the biggest flash in the pan like
yeah after a month it was dead right
because you couldn't you get you get
your Pokemon and that's it
I know they brought out the raids yeah
but it still didn't feel that but that
was also like I think it was like a year
after yeah yeah yeah I I hung on for a
bit because I was a bit hopy and
thinking it would come back uh it didn't
but I I remembered I did a couple things
so we went to Chicago for the raids and
they had like the first big Pokemon go
event and then like the servers didn't
work because it was too many people that
was fun yeah
um and then we did the Yokohama Pikachu
event oh yeah uh which I was talking
about last night and then they launched
Gen 2 and I was in Japan for that as
well but yeah and then it was done in a
year kind of yeah right and then four
and I came out
no actually the first phone that I
filmed was a sponsored video oh really
because I I remember when fortnite came
out uh because I was I was playing FPS
games around that time and it was kind
of like it was not super big right away
like I think everyone remembers fortnite
just blowing up instantly but it was
pretty slow yeah very slow like Pokemon
go was definitely Bang Yeah Yeah but
like fortnite was like gradually over
time because it was still pubg I think
it was big right and then yeah just a
couple updates came out the ninja
started getting these viewers going and
then it definitely hit the hit the yeah
because I was gonna ask I was like from
from someone who like I played like one
fortnite game and I was like yeah I
think it's not really for me personally
but like I've it's always been kind of
an anomaly to see because like you
always hear about like games blowing up
but I feel like the the blow up of
fortnite and like the magnitude they
grew to eventually was almost like
unprecedented like it was like at the
time there was not really a game that
had blown up that much like overnight
why why do you think it was like why why
was it Fortnight that you think was like
the game that just exploded and became
what it is today yeah you know what you
try to dissect it I actually don't know
because like yeah Minecraft was would
you say Minecraft would Minecraft
Minecraft was like a very gradual rise
yeah yeah yeah and then it just kind of
dominated Minecraft also had its like
ups and downs as well it was like yeah
for a little bit and then it kind of
came back yeah everyone thought
Minecraft was dead then I had a
Resurgence and it was dead again then
it's like always there's always yeah
it's never gonna die it's like Lego you
know what I mean it's it's like yeah it
will fall off like a month or two and
then it will come back because you know
the kids will always play you know it's
too many good mods yeah and I'm thinking
about going back and I thought I'd never
go back
but yeah I don't know it's hard I don't
know how fortnite like and even like
being a credit the time it was just kind
of like
it was pubg but the graphics looked for
me it was looking on the thumbnail like
the colors looked good vibrant yeah you
know when you compare it to like you
said pubg and H1 uh Z1 like they're all
really kind of ugly games yeah very
great it's like an ugly I mean it's just
ugly it's like cod that somehow looks
worse than Cod yeah one of these games
so yeah I think it's definitely that as
well it's very more it's easy to like
show a kid fortnite be like oh yeah the
saturation yeah like and you get a gun
it's a it's a gold gun it's like oh okay
this is all like kind of like hitting
the serotonin points in your head yeah
yeah that's true it's it's fun like even
if you're not good at it when you when
you find a purple gun like oh it must be
good and then it's like it sucks or
something yeah well you know you know I
feel like as someone who's like never
actually played a single game of
fortnite yes I am that person I like
fortnite for a while so yeah really yeah
what seasons oh [__] oh you're like
it was right for the season before
Thanos joined oh okay that was a good
one yeah okay I remember that because I
remember I quit and Thanos came out and
I was like just when I thought I was out
yeah just when I thought I was out they
dragged me right back in yeah and I
remember when that happened that was
insane that was wild yeah at this time
they hadn't done any collabs no it was
the I think yeah the first one and like
I started with a playable Thanos which
is mad but like I don't think anybody in
gaming had even done anything close to
that no no no no no and even even now
fortnite is getting all of the anime IP
like collaborations that the attackers
Attack on Titan Naruto Japan right now
like yeah every bus stop there's just
like a [__] huge ad for like oh the
casa and Aaron are in fortnite now
they're just like what is this timeline
we're meeting a lot about fortnite but I
think there is generally so much
interesting stuff to talk about about
it's a case and how it affects it online
for sure yeah yeah because like yeah
like I said like a lot of these IP like
Naruto like my hero Academia Dragon Ball
it's some of like the eyepiece that the
Japanese are so [__] protective over
and have never collabed with like like
an outside kind of like entity yeah like
in in the history of the industry so the
fact that what broke that curse was
fortnite you know as much as we meme it
up is [__] impressive no absolutely
yeah yeah I I wonder if they'll ever get
Nintendo or Pokemon my answer is no I
don't think they know like I think
that's the one that they yeah you're
right they are very protective I think
there's another level of that yeah these
boys right here the Mario boys they I
don't think they're gonna I just I just
can't imagine Luigi like emoting over a
kill you know
like Nintendo would never let Mario have
a gun man are you [__] kidding me
I think a lot of these companies were
protective but you know there's
definitely a sign that you know because
when you go to Japan you can see that
like you know Levi's on cleaning
products or um
you know they in Japan they're not
nearly as protective as they are
compared to like overseas so yeah they
clearly were open to licensing out the
the IP and the characters for stuff that
doesn't really make sense for the
characters I mean would leave out with
cleaning it does but yeah I have a
Roomba that uh the voice is just Levi
nowhere yeah so when you turn it on it's
just Levi being like it's time to clean
they obviously have a history of being
willing to give out the IP and I think
it was just a case of no one was writing
the big enough checks I think yeah yeah
it must have come along and offered some
crazy yeah system for it because I think
that's what it would take for them to be
like all right yeah I guess yeah sure
did you see that latest one-piece
McDonald's collab in Japan
yeah chicken they've remade the one
piece opening with like gold Roger uh
like having like a chicken burger and
recite and reciting the uh reciting the
opening monologue we're like if you want
to find the chicken burger you can find
it in McDonald's
now yeah so it's it's obvious that they
are willing to work with IPS
um and yeah it's impressive that
fortnite has had this massive
International growth that has like
literally like reshaped the industry did
you know it was gonna like blow up or
was it kind of just like a feeling yeah
there's a feeling it was definitely a
feeling it was like kind of just like
and at the time like in this part of my
career I just gotten off the Pokemon go
hype train so I was very much just like
looking for the new kind of game to set
up on because I'm not
I don't know about variety a variety for
YouTube in the gaming Niche is is hard
because like you'll get viewers that
come to watch you for a certain game
yeah you play something else you have
your viewership and back then I thought
the algorithm was very based on like
your average viewership I don't know if
it actually was but that was just in my
head
um so I'd just like to be on one game
and that way I could kind of do
different things with the one game and I
think it being this kind of malleable
game where you can use to to tell a
story or interact with the community
like it was it was perfect for me at the
time and it still is it's just
I I think a lot of what killed the hype
for like content creation on YouTube for
fortnite was just like Tick Tock to be
honest right right like it just like
sped everything up in it
you know you'd sit there back then I
used to upload like 30 minute videos in
fortnite and it'll be great you could
not get away with that today generally
what Drew to fortnite initially because
you got addicted to the game yeah so
well brand deal right right right okay
okay but we've all had brand deals okay
not every brand deal that we do that we
get we're like okay I'm probably the
worst to say this because I get addicted
to every brand deal that I get sent so I
I I get it but like what what about the
game due to it and kept you playing
afterwards I'm sure it wasn't the only
brand deal you got right no no for sure
yeah it was so I guess did the brand and
the video performed well right yeah
right so that's definitely gonna fire
off that uh that dopamine kick for sure
it's like all right I want another kick
give me get let's go again
um uh yeah just
pretty much getting back in there I was
actually challenging to win as well
um like very in the early days so it was
you know actual fun experience to try
and win a game
um so like just recounting that and then
like you know you're throwing these
little challenges where it's like okay
can I use a certain color weapon and
like that spicy for a bit and you could
do kind of videos with other people in
the community
I don't really know what like just kept
me there though I honestly it was just
fun
was it not overrated now now it wasn't
is it now is the question right like I
don't know it's kind of a bit you think
it's changed or anything well it's it's
gone through two massive stages at least
I mean
um when I played fortnite when I when I
did uh it was kind of I liked it and
then you know I didn't play it for like
a two two three months and then it it
was crushing it because all the Thanos
stuff and then I came back to play it
like a year later and everyone was
insane at building so if you don't know
fortnite has this mechanic where what
made it unique is a battle royale was
that you could build structures right
right but honestly structures you could
build vertical walls floors or ceilings
and then like ramps yeah and the whole
idea is that you should build pretty
quickly to move or make it make a cover
right and it's a cool system and it made
sense but then what ended up happening
was that people started getting insanely
good at building right yeah like and I
mean like Fast yeah it's like let's say
you found someone someone would erect
like a whole [__] structure that was
like yeah like 0.1 seconds like this guy
and then I I'd be playing against him
like this [__] sucks I'm logging off
yeah I don't want to [__] play this
is something horrible for beginners yeah
and I think that's when it started to
kind of slow down a little bit and then
they had this massive idea where they
were like fortnite is falling off let's
remove building so they just moved the
entire mechanic and they were like guys
it's good again and that was that like
whole kind of pitch trying to get people
back into it am I correct and saying
yeah no got a lot of the casuals back
yeah for sure that like reminisce on the
old times yeah definitely got a few of
them back here I think I think the way I
found out about it I just remembered
this was when they did that collab with
like Travis Scott yeah oh yeah the
Travis Scott and marshmallow concert
yeah like I think that's how I found out
about it because I was like you didn't
find out about fortnite until then I had
known about it but I remember I remember
when the Travis Scott console was
happening that was like all over the
Internet because it's like fortnite this
[__] game somehow Hal got like a
serious like mainstream artist to do
like a virtual concert in their game and
I'm like what yeah how did that happen
and then he did the [__] McDonald's
thing and I'm like okay this guy will
shop for a check anyway
always comes back to McDonald's
yeah I think for me like I always knew
about fortnite but I I think the moment
I realized how big it was was I guess
one ninja who was just overnight it felt
like overnight just became like the
biggest streamer and like the face of
like twitch and gaming for like a while
yeah uh and just like the the first like
Esports event that they did as well
where they had like the [__]
ridiculous prize pool yeah 100 yeah I
think it was 30 mil there's 100 Mil
throughout the year they spent on
competitive yeah yeah World Cup went
crazy yeah I I played in the um not the
solos and the Duos where like all the
prize was I was in like the creative one
okay so like as a team captain became
dead last okay
how much I go for dead loss 20 bucks no
this is fortnite here
300K I'm pissed about it to be honest
yeah there's literally like a clip of me
in the last game because it was like it
was like a they're like parkour you guys
like parkour games they run around don't
fall off yeah essentially like yeah
actually have to like not fall in the
lava literally that right okay so it was
a lot of like that different type of
competitive aspect and so they're all
these like professional parkour Runners
that we build as a team professionals
they bagged out 300K so
um but I remember those like on the last
game like my team had died
and I was sitting out I just literally
sat there emote crying knowing I can't
[__] win like did you did you go to a
physical location finally this was at
the World Cup it was the day before in
New York what was the uh all the way out
to New York from Australia yeah I was in
Toronto at the time so it was an easy
flight all right okay okay how did he
qualify for that uh well that one I was
a captain so like I was like you chose
the team I chose the team yeah yeah so
it was like kind of I made a map and
people qualified by like running my map
really fast okay well we took him over
and got dead last was it was this
because you were already like
pre-established so yeah like okay we
want you to be a team captain or did was
there like an actual like qualification
process no it was it was very much that
yeah okay it was like me ninja uh
scissors uh and a bunch of other
International creators so you had to
just be a captain of four random people
you'd never met before yeah how was that
yeah you met them in person I sure yeah
yeah you must be so bizarre yeah it's
like oh while you guys a goats you ran
my map really quick like let's try and
bag out now let's do
[__] me
yeah between five of them no like 200k
50k I think 50k each yeah
USD by the way
okay fortnite was handing out these bags
that they never handed out anymore
like yo that's why it's overrated
no I mean they are handing out like uh
like I don't know if you guys saw like
the the Unreal Engine fortnite
announcement like it took over Twitter
for a couple days and was like whoa this
is fortnite now and it's like
essentially you can like water for this
yep yeah you would have you would have
seen all the timeline
um so that's like a big thing where like
now 40 of the revenue that comes out of
the item shop gets split between Play
Time on Battle Royale and creative maps
that are made right so like they had nap
bags there that's that's a definitely a
good place so you can literally become
like I guess making it your job yeah in
like uh
that's like the the roadblocks yeah it
is literally the Roblox five Roblox does
so well they give people who make the
most popular Maps a lot of money well
they don't even give them the money they
actually give them tokens right well so
they don't have this in fortnite but
Roblox
you can sell things in the game for
Robux you can get like a gun in the game
yeah and it's very like kind of pay to
win kind of yeah
but roblox's system is very very
questionable yeah it is a lot of like
very [__] they have a whole Stock
Exchange which they shouldn't have well
in game yeah like a legit like
functioning oh yeah I know for the items
yeah yeah something worth like hundreds
of thousands yeah and it's like yeah and
bear in mind this is for kids youngest
demographic in gaming probably they
should not I I just I just got hit
um I'm I'm becoming my dad now no I was
just about to say I'm like this is what
this is this is what my dad must feel
like when I hear about like
[__] I [__] get it like you might
okay imagine your kid comes along it's
like Mom Dad I'm gonna become a
professional fortnite map Builder and
you're just like I get it now because
I'm like this is how my dad must have
felt when I said I wanted to be a
YouTuber why are you sad son box went
down two points yesterday
I just sold and it's there's
um there's been like a lot of stories in
Roblox about dudes like basically just
getting like kids to make maps for them
yeah yeah
get a bunch of kids and they'll make
them make stuff for them and then
they'll just take all the money yeah
dude who like yeah [__] yeah it's it's
it's such a weird it's about not trying
to compare fortnite because it actually
sounds like it has a pretty good system
yeah Traders but like Roblox has gone
down the other route where it's like we
will literally give anyone money as long
as you make stuff wait did you do any
like Roblox content at all no I actually
oh I did like I dabbled a little bit but
like I didn't get into it at all right
um but yeah I used to run like Minecraft
servers yeah um yeah that was my first
kind of experience like running a
business I guess
um because those would run in a way
where it's like come on and you pay for
a rank and then it's like you know
building content and then filming a
series to help promote the server that
was like really really fun for me back
in the day yeah I saw uh I saw I was
looking through your channel this
morning and I was like oh I see you're
one of the Minecraft youtubers who were
doing parody songs yeah
I didn't sing them though I just like
produced them right like yeah that was
fun yeah there was some I think that's
actually my most viewed video yeah
yeah dude I remember because like back
in the day man like when when Minecraft
was that it's like first first Peak
there was like all the big Minecraft
creators were doing these parody songs
they were getting stupid views yeah but
I don't think they'd ever really make
money because they get claimed I think
that one's claimed oh really yeah it was
like a parody of a popular yeah yeah
Captain Sparkles did a bunch of well his
one of them he had to change the song
completely oh my um one of his OG ones
but like I think the big ones are like
still good it depends like your
relationship with diamond swords from
Damascus
some OG internet like gold there
this episode is sponsored by Harrys
whether your ritual is minimal or
elevated level up your shave game with
Harry sleekest razor yet the craft
handle the Innovative design delivers
the same great shape you expect with
German engineered Blaze that Glides
across your skin and a killer New Look
experience the latest and gracious in
Harry's Razer lineup delivered straight
to your door for just 10 at harrys.com
trash taste
and we have the biggest Harry simp right
here I have been using Harry's since we
were first sponsored by them and I
refuse to shave with anyone else in fact
I shaved with them this morning for a
lovely oh yeah that's clean dog and you
can experience Harry sleekest handle yet
with their craft handle starter set for
just ten dollars mind you it's valued at
17 but you can get it for just 10. it
includes a craft handle five blade
German engineered razor cartridge
shaving gel and a travel cover plus you
can schedule replacement blade delivery
whenever you need them with refills as
low as 2. I don't know I don't know
they're the goats elevate your shave in
the latest and greatest in Harry's razor
handle lineup today get your 17 craft
handle starter set for just ten dollars
at harrys.com trash taste that's
harrys.com trash station I'll say it one
more time harry's.com slash trash taste
let them cook so you got your start in
Minecraft right yeah yeah Minecraft was
um was was the was the start yeah I was
in how do you differentiate yourself in
Minecraft as well so when you start out
Minecraft how do you grow when you
because everyone's doing Minecraft yeah
what was it
um I think I went to like kind of a VR
content phase for like three months in
those early days like the HTC Vive was
picking up
um I was doing just random flash games
like after Minecraft before Pokemon go I
had like yeah three four five months
didn't
um I'd like to think I was like building
up a community people that were there to
like just watch me play random games
yeah yeah
um and then yeah just kind of played
whatever I felt was fun and that that's
probably the overarching theme of like
the channel for last 10 years I won't
play something if I don't enjoy it yeah
like that's pretty much it all
aggressive yeah because like I normally
see like a trend in gaming YouTubers
especially some people who start off
doing a game like Minecraft is that they
find such trouble kind of like doing
other content outside when that kind of
like content kind of falls off but
you've managed to like switch content
and switch games like several times yeah
how did you how'd you go about like
building an audience around a game
around a new game or a new style of
content yeah it's tough because a lot of
times it's like a gamble it's like all
right I've got this and I know I'll keep
this yeah but you if you don't change
you're just gonna eventually just go
lower and lower yeah yeah yeah so yeah
it's it's taking a Gamble and you're
it's it's two steps back one step
forward because your your first video on
a new game is gonna be gonna do worse
you just gotta stomach that
um but yeah just just getting it in
there and trying really hard to make
that new content for that game better
and I feel like it's even easier these
days than it was back then right I feel
like almost every YouTube video now
these days is kind of like a tick tock
and like it could bang or it could not
bang and it's like whereas in the past
be like oh your next video is going to
do worse because the last one did worse
yeah yeah and he gets like kind of that
hole but now it feels like you just come
with a good video it doesn't matter who
you are yeah it can bang hard like I've
seen challenge like 10K subscribers get
videos like millions of views yeah and I
feel like ah another good thing about
like the new algorithm is that I feel
like there's a safety net now because
even if a video doesn't bang like
immediately I've noticed even if you
change the thumbnail or title maybe it
wasn't like optimized the best if
there's still an opportunity that you
can kind of like revive old videos uh
whereas before if you uploaded a video
it was 10 out of 10 you're like it's
done I can't I can't [__] do it next
video I'm irrelevant I'm dead yeah the
10 out of 10s hit different yeah
and you get enough of them next one
can't be 10 out of 10 you know yeah you
start building them up yeah I heard
they're gonna get rid of it
really yeah the whole one out of 10
ranking system for like mental health
yeah I get it there's our room could
could not be true yeah Fair Bible Source
I think like somewhere in the Beast Camp
I heard it from oh okay okay okay yeah
because I know they've been talking
about it for a while because a lot of
content creators have kind of you know
been like this is not helping me in the
worst way to start the day you guys like
me were like first thing you do in the
morning what do you do you check your
phone uh I actually don't check YouTube
analytics at all no okay I've stopped it
yeah yeah I think yeah just something I
just kind of realized like I actually
just like my days when I don't look at
it yeah but I look today because I have
one of the videos nine out of ten which
I which I'm fine with because 10 out of
10 is when I'm like because my channel
is bad yeah yeah so if it goes below
that I'm like oh this is bad
you know what you mean yeah you upload
an absolute stinker and you're like okay
as long as it's not as bad as that yeah
yeah I don't know what you guys are
talking about YouTube killed my
depression by removing dislikes I oh my
God I I am no longer depressed now thank
you YouTube
oh not not that I can still totally see
it when I go to my YouTube dashboard or
anything you know all right it's not
there publicly so I'm happy now yeah
yeah congratulations by the way because
uh I I actually first found out about
you through a Sony V2 video like
normally when Sony V2 makes a video it's
about the fall of a YouTuber yeah it's
one of his few like positive kind of
like videos hey shout out my boys
um no yeah that was a weird one uh I'm
expecting one though to be like
I don't know look we're in different
days now the channels is it is it weird
to have somebody kind of talk about your
YouTube Journey it's cool it's cool it's
cool I actually really enjoyed watching
the video I remember when that came out
yeah
I think
um yeah no no that was a trip it's a
trip though yeah definitely it's like
weird but nah it was cool I care what
you think it was it like yeah it's
pretty it's pretty accurate at the time
right right um yeah I mean look these
days and like like running power and
like that whole kind of Esports side of
things and everything around that I've
had a lot less time to focus on my own
channel right
um going through a bit of a break right
now
awaiting uh you know a sunny V2 kind of
house
I actually want to make an addendum uh
it fell off yeah so you mentioned you
started an Esports agency Yeah well yeah
Esports org uh back in 20
20 right when covered started right yeah
where did that idea come from so back uh
in the World Cup days of fortnite I was
actually playing a bit of competitive
Fortnight uh with a pro player we were
trying to qualify for World Cup and I
really enjoyed like that competitive
Journey
um and I wasn't that good but the player
I was playing with was really good that
was fresh
um and he low-key hiki carried me
um sorry this guy's qualified no we got
like sixth you know sixth or seventh in
our best Duos week you need to get first
uh to qualify so because yeah not many
spots for Australia but right yeah I
really enjoyed the competitive journey
and I just liked being involved in just
competitive Fortnight and so yeah
Australia doesn't have much of a scene
for Esports so I just wanted to to get
behind it and yeah really start start
making content for a competitive
Fortnight was uh yeah definitely a big
drive for me and just bringing people
together in Australia right was it more
to like grow the Australian kind of like
East full scene or because like a a big
thing is that starting an Esports
organization uh worst Financial thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah how the hell's that been man
what's the meme of like uh moisten
Ludwig burning money over fire yeah yeah
pretty accurate
um yeah look it's uh it's a challenge
and that's probably why I like it
because it's like
uh it's the first business I've ever
done or business adventure that just
loses money and it's like right
fundamentally that's [__] hard yeah
it's like fundamentally that's like to
me it's like well this is a failure
right because it doesn't make money but
it's like it's not about money it's
about honestly just bringing people
together making content because it's
more than just Esports it's it's a
Content Journey
um we do like a lot of IRL stuff a lot
of fortnite stuff
we have a rocket League team as well so
we do trying to get those boys involved
as well right
um sticking in like the epic games
metaverse I suppose as far as like their
titles right
uh but yeah it's just it's fun it's
different it's really challenging but I
think we're making some good moves so
tell me like the entire process about
how what goes behind actually just
making an Esports organization from from
the start okay so yeah like who do you
talk to yeah yeah
and like well this is the other thing as
well I was like I think I think it's
just me and moist are like the only ones
playing with their own money yeah I
think like so I think first step for
most people is seek investors yeah I
can't Venture Capital yeah maybe yeah or
toast as well yeah actually yeah yeah no
that's true uh yeah
um but yeah I think it's just honestly
so so step one find money find money
find money find money you want to burn
how much what percentage of what I have
can I earn yeah literally well that's
that's there that's the conversation
um and uh yeah you just start with the
like I have a really good uh kind of
business partner that I've had from like
kind of the start uh his name is Billy
like started off in like kind of very
professional lawyer services so he
helped me out with getting everything
started and brought over kind of my team
from like my editing team and stuff that
really built from my channel and just
try to like scale it a little bit right
um and then just yeah hiring people and
Contracting players how do you how'd you
go about like finding players that you
want to contract for your team and your
organization yeah like trolls or no it's
very much just like what did what are
their goals and do they align with ours
right so our goals aren't like our goals
uh I mean we're trying to definitely
this is winning not the goal yeah
don't be [__]
but that's like I feel like that's kind
of a fallacies like winning for teams I
feel like is the highest priority right
it's like I get it right you're not
going in to lose yeah you're obviously
trying to win but the top or the top
level they got this money glitch coming
in from somewhere I don't know where it
is but they're spending so much on the
top player so to win it's very expensive
and that's why no one makes any money
yeah right because they're just ego
bowling each other to try and get the
best players so I actually like for me
it's about picking the best talent in
Australia and how we can prop them up to
compete at an international level
because right the meme is Australia goes
overseas we don't win and it's like you
look at League I don't know if you guys
fought any yeah yeah yeah so all my uh
knowledge of Esports come from is
basically like League yeah dissolved
yeah well they got rid of the league oh
yeah yeah because they were like no one
no one's no one's watching no one's
watching and then so there's the time
zone from like a commercial side you're
only putting it out to people who live
in Australia what 30 million yeah so
that's your viewership and do they like
Esports well not really because we don't
win so it's it's kind of this weird
relationship right so I think that's a
big part of it and yeah trying to prop
up those Australian players so that they
can actually compete at the highest
level right um one thing I've always
been curious about is okay you find the
players because you know in the in the
top kind of echelon of whatever game
you're playing there's only a few you
can pick from that are like can perform
at the top level how did you go about
finding coaching
um yeah you know that kind of getting
that environment to really coach them
into a Esports kind of like environment
yeah I've actually been pretty lucky
with that one the coaches is actually
not too hard oh really had some really
good like people in you know fortnite
and Rocket League who have just been
from other organizations and just
getting them involved like no that one's
actually a pretty easy one yeah what do
you think makes a good coach because
it's I've always found it so interesting
because like our coach is doing a panel
on this a dream hack by the way oh
really okay okay awesome I'll [__] go
there yeah I'm not enough I'm qualified
to speak on it but like his his coaching
philosophy this is Gemma the rocket
league coach is yeah he doesn't come
from a much of a gameplay perspective he
comes from more of a mental and like
like uh psychological perspective right
right you know trying to not tilt and
setting up the player is best for those
kind of Rocket league is an interesting
one like it's very tilt-heavy uh right
that kind of specific Esports I would
argue every uh useful way yeah so I've
seen the smash compilation yeah you know
because Rockley doesn't give you much
time to breathe yeah Legend if you die
you have 30 seconds to like compose
yourself and like all right okay I'll
get it back in the game yeah rocket
League's like oh I've just tilted and
we've lost four goals yeah so yeah it's
a fun one though I really like rocket
League because I think anybody can
understand what's going on yeah right
that's why I love it that's what I love
about the fighting game Community which
is like obviously fighting games people
will tell but that's part of like the
community right it's it's the soul they
embrace it you know that's that's the
best part of it yeah I'm curious
um from like the Esports uh perspective
of
like let's say you have
um like legalization jib 10 teams right
who compete every every week or whatever
you know where do you have to be on that
like in that top ten for your team to be
kind of breaking even or making money
because and I imagine the problem
balloons even more so with like fortnite
or Apex when there's like you know
there's so many people right because at
least in league right maybe there's 50
people total you know Apex maybe there's
you know 180 people you have to kind of
get to that level where somehow everyone
can make just enough to survive yeah and
I thought like what does it look like
like if if we're in a game of fortnite
which I don't know how many people are
in a fortnight game 100
like yeah like okay let's say we're in a
pro fortnite match right yeah how many
of that hundreds are living off of
playing it professionally and how many
of them have to do other stuff in that
spare time I I saw an article on this
depends on the region uh in Australia I
don't like like five percent even then
like the prize pool they really nerfed
it off the World Cup like it's gone down
ever since right
um yeah and that's why I honestly I
don't think you could have learned from
a pure competitive standpoint that's why
we try to really get the players
involved with content because that
that's how you make it that's that's
what you pitch I know it's like so kind
of like over said at this point of like
oh
my content yeah it's like turning you
know if you have like a Michael Jordan
right you're like hey you should do
Space Jam you should yeah you should do
it's like hey this is how you should
stream I don't want to stream more stuff
yeah like diversify while you're like I
guess name value is like at its highest
right just to make sure to be like all
right yeah you know you can make any
money in other revenues just in case you
[__] fall Cliff skill wise and you
know you're not winning these games or
whatever right but it's a hard
conversation to have with them because
like their their goal is just win yeah
it's not about like you know if I put on
a stream I play worse so I don't stream
and like that's a hard you know chat
about out of players because I'm like
I'd kill to have your skill and be able
to create content and stream like I
would actually kill for that but like
for them it's just like
got thorough last week and we're looking
for forest and it's like I'm you know
that's part of our agenda too we want to
win too so it's like yeah I'm just yeah
more trying to preach that kind of
stability because like Esports is very
Cutthroat it is it is like okay like in
your experience even if any Esports
organization was consistently winning
and that's all they were doing is that
still enough to like is the prize pool
enough to make them a profitable
business or something that can break
even even yeah because even that's a
weird one like I I for me it's like do
people care about the org like that
that's my biggest goal it's like I don't
really care about winning it like going
back to that yeah I mean great we want
to win we want to build a story don't
get me wrong
um and we're you know we're working
towards that and because just because
you can really use that win with a story
to create a reason for people to care
yeah
um but I think that's where like a lot
of you know
these orgs go for just that winning and
it's like oh we won okay cool yeah I
might get a few Partnerships out of that
like I'm sure everyone loves being with
the winning team
um but I think if you're not able to
tell the story as well then it gets a
bit rough and I think G2 would be a good
example of a team that does that yeah
um like really tells the story and wins
well they've they've a huge content
Focus yeah they just aren't doing it
they're like well we'll always have a
crew yeah and we'll always film stuff I
think that's but also at least for the
league team they have quite a lot of
characters who are pretty pretty
engaging and yeah yeah well I think from
like a spectator like kind of like
Viewpoint
um obviously like winning is the easiest
way to get someone invested in your team
because obviously there are a lot of
people who just like cheering for a team
that wins yeah yeah uh but saying this
as like saying this as an Arsenal fan
who got in uh back back in the back in
the good old days and now is like a kind
of like a G2 fan uh for leads yeah
[Applause]
um but one thing that really drew me
towards both of these teams
um before the winning was just having
this really exciting playstyle or just
like having being like excited every
time to see them play because they had
like a really kind of different play
style as well so even if you're just
doing something exciting in the game uh
aside from just making content as well
uh because from my perspective
I started watching that content after I
saw the exciting things that they were
doing in game so I was like [__] I want
to want to check these guys out and now
and then after that was did I become a
fan did you do you have like a kind of
like a
let's say like a strategy to try and get
people invested in your organization
yeah and I mean it it definitely is
mainly around that content Focus like I
mean for our Channel on on power we
definitely try to involve as much around
the community and the content creators
within Australia yeah
um to try and very much get people on
board so that when they see us in a
rocket League game or when they see us
in a fortnight it's like oh these guys
create great content and that's why I
want to get behind them yeah
um that that is the strategy for us at
the moment I would say do you guys have
a Content house or like no so we've a
Powerhouse that's literally what it was
called it was called a Powerhouse house
we did it for like one month in Sydney
and we had our Pro players come play on
zero pain compete in the finals yeah um
and then we just filmed a bunch of
content it was a great uh kind of test
yeah to see if it would work and the
videos did really well
um competitive players I think we've got
a top five in there
um and that was a good test so now we're
actually building a studio in Melbourne
um which hopefully opens up in like a
couple months and that'll be the next
big kind of investment from us to really
have creative people there I won't be
more so for the players be more so for
the team and the content to really Irish
yeah I mean a lot of the Orcs are
focusing on you know like merchandise
and apparel like building kind of some
form of like turning it into engagement
yeah brand and loyalty in the in the
brand which makes sense right because
YouTubers is one of the biggest ways
they make money is much yeah it's one of
the best margins in terms of uh you know
what the viewer gets something and they
get to support you so it's it's a good
good way have gone about it but I wonder
wonder how long it'll keep being like
that I wonder yeah like how involved are
you in terms of like bringing your own
personal branding of like your you know
content creator YouTube kind of side of
things into this Esports organization
because I feel like you guys like you
and moist and Ludwig and toast have a
inherent advantage in that you already
have a lot of people invested in you as
a person uh so bringing that kind of
like brand power to your organization
means it's an easy way to kind of like
create people who are invested in your
uh yeah team 100 and it's like kind of
like the story already started 10 years
ago and like this is like the the end of
it like or I suppose the current stage
of it in the organization
um yeah it's definitely bringing a lot
of that branding like I came from a full
content creator perspective I was like
the only way we're even gonna get close
to profitable is just making content so
let's just start there and yeah work off
players who have you know I suppose I
can't even say with you to like more of
a personality yeah and you know if they
win that's great too like yeah love that
that's and we've got a few of those guys
they're great characters and just really
want to get involved in content but also
put in hard work at being the best of
their game is it ever a question of you
know
can can the the Esports agency that's
like like you mentioned like Maurice or
whatever
can can that a can that org ever Eclipse
your own kind of influence and following
or something that's always in the shadow
of I I would say it's probably above
mine right now really be honest yeah
well and that's nice well and it's not
even because that's because many my
numbers have dropped
look but that's the thing is that like I
I run power I don't have like a CEO I
looked at it and they were all like hey
Foreigner K year and I was like hey I'll
do it myself and then which is probably
dumb in hindsight because like I've
definitely sacrificed a lot of time on
my own channel um because this has been
my main priority right but also I think
it's whatever you enjoy doing yeah if
that's something that is more rewarding
for you and with your current stage of
life then like yeah like you know how to
make videos if you want to go back you
could you could easily start that grind
and then get back into it I think yeah
and I get tempted a lot and I'm like I'm
taking a few months off like I think I
was telling you guys about traveling
like gonna travel the next two months
and just focus on Power and just kind of
put my channel to the back for a bit and
then maybe come back to the studio in
Melbourne and maybe rejig up my channel
again but at the moment yeah it's my
number one priorities is power because I
think winning with the team is way
cooler than winning by yourself yeah and
that's what the channel was for 10 years
just doing well but it's like
you know you you know party with your
other content creators but it's like
imagine parting with the team yeah I
mean that's just so much cooler and so
much more rewarding for sure could you
just say it's the friends we made in
life
it's not about winning we're a family we
take care of each other let's sound some
anime [__] right here yeah it's very
animated yeah I didn't ask and I should
have asked this what games did is your
old computer yeah so it's it's fortnite
we started there okay
um and then rocket League
uh which we actually we were the first
Australian team to ever sweep an N A
team in rocket League earlier this year
so I consider that a huge W for us D2 as
well by the way
yeah we love that one we love that uh
and then yeah fortnite we've got uh six
players uh one of which got top five at
dreamhack San Diego
um and he's gone to gamers8 for that big
two million dollar tournament uh later
this year [__] yeah I know yeah no
um I suppose I mean I think a similar or
example but we don't take any prize
money yeah like that's kind of theirs
and we just help build everything else
around it yeah yeah yeah um which I
think is definitely probably the better
way of doing it much more sense yeah
how's it feel seeing your team compete
so good like okay so here's the thing
have you guys watched like moist rocket
League watch parties yeah yeah they're
so good like
yes
[Applause]
so like I watch him right and he's like
I was back in the spring major last year
we were competing and I was streaming
hours on YouTube but we only made it
past one round and it was depressing
because it was like zero three zero
three were out and I was like [__]
um and then I'm I'm sitting there living
through Charlie watching his team win
I'm like [__] man I want that song and
they want it and then they won it and I
was like [__] man I feel so good for him
right now that like I've done the
opposite spectrum of like stream my team
just getting absolutely rinsed by The
Face Clan and just another team and it's
just like I think I've watched Charlie
his team lose it's like it's depressing
it's depressing yeah it also that's
that's the journey but and it's also the
content yeah right like you're getting
depressed is they're loving watching
your pain I saw a lot of just [__]
like looking so defeated when his team
lost it it was kind of fun yeah
because it's like it's it's like you
said like you see at the highest you get
the lows and that's what makes it great
yeah you see a man who's invested like a
yeah yeah it's like if you watched Your
Arsenal but every time Arsenal lost you
would lose 50k
it's so much more fun to watch
it's like this is great
it's a deeper level in the game it's
like higher Stakes because money is also
time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
no actually like the next level of
sports betting you know it's like it's
like I don't know sports but I make my
own Esports team but also it's kind of
five head because they just they're
buying essentially just guaranteed
content for themselves yeah yeah because
you get that every single week or
whatever they're playing you get to
stream it and you get to then make money
off of those streams yeah it's good in
the content calendar it's like for
streamers specifically as well like I am
not much of a streamer like I started
making YouTube content but I did do like
a two-year uh YouTube deal streaming a
while back and that was where I really
got into streaming and
it was interesting to learn like yeah
not into the stream because you you got
the YouTube deal as like the first wave
yeah we were on the first wave of it
back in the day uh that when mixer was
really starting to pipe up and exercise
ninja and then it first streamer War
started and it cool now it's actually
kind of back now kick yeah this is heard
a couple Rumblings going on yeah
this is episode is sponsored by vessi
shoes I will never leave the house
unless I'm wearing bessies if you've
seen a picture of any of us in the past
few years or months we are most
definitely wearing a pair of ashes and
there's a good reason tell them why God
I do not have another pair of shoes that
are as comfortable as breathable and so
they're just waterproof one of my
biggest complaints about life is that
when I'd go outside in England I'd go
out into the rain and I'd always come
back with wet socks
and with their four-way stretch
lightweight comfort and easy and on off
accessibility it is the perfect shoe and
best of all super easy to clean honestly
one of the big reasons is that I don't
have to think about my Footwear whenever
I take a trip or something because
vessies is good for whatever occasion
you can think of they're so good that I
wore them to God's wedding so you know
that they are suitable for any situation
anywhere you are in the world so if you
want to join the vessi gang like we have
then make sure to go over to vesi.com
trash taste and use our coupon code
trash taster checkout to get 15 off your
order do it now see you there thank you
very much to vesi for sponsoring us
today back to the video one thing I
wanted to ask actually is like are you
planning to like kind of extend to other
games as well with power yeah definitely
definitely I think that's in the books
for yeah 2023 this year
um it's it's and that's like kind of
part of it is like surveying which game
to go next uh would you be interested in
like because you know you you obviously
like massive Pokemon fan right like have
you ever thought about like going into
like the competitor of Pokemon scene or
that's interesting that started really
hitting my like for you page on YouTube
yeah it's like really blown up recently
is it Wolfie yeah Wolfie yeah he makes
some great content yeah like really good
storytelling he's been uh innovating but
also when you when you're playing with a
Nintendo property so yeah the answer is
no but yeah yeah
booming thought of like when are they
gonna decide they don't like this yeah I
mean I've seen all the smash like [__]
storms going on yeah yeah it's crazy
that they just don't want any Esports
they just they've actively where other
other games like embrace it will pay
hundreds of millions of dollars to get
something Nintendo will actively be like
[__] this [__] you don't play all games
longer than we tell you I just don't
think they really like understand the
scene enough and they I I feel like it's
gone way too long we can't use that as
an excuse I think they understand it
they just don't want it yeah I feel like
that is not their goals they are that
[__] Granddad who's just like all
right what is Esports I don't understand
this apparently watch Real Sports that's
not real Sports yeah because it like it
feels like you know especially in Japan
I don't know how big the Esports scene
is in Japan uh but I know it's like
almost non-existent in terms of like
league is it is it valorant or is it
valent's pretty big yeah
Apex won the Battle Royale war in Japan
oh yeah which is even close yeah and
like they're getting Aaron Yeagers and
they're still not winning
our posters everywhere now they're
trying to win a war over there I think
it's like kids kids love fortnite in
Japan yeah yeah but like the moment they
kind of get older yeah it's Apex
everyone plays yeah but but Valentine is
also massively taken off yeah uh yeah
YouTubers for that yeah a lot of
YouTubers actually yeah there's push
Apex
um yeah right I think it was actually
the V tubers that originally especially
with Apex blew it up in Japan because
like there was like a bunch of like
pretty top level Japanese YouTubers who
got really [__] good at Apex well
they also have like uh I think it's not
maybe bi-weekly or monthly uh YouTuber
Apex tournaments oh yeah yeah pretty big
yeah basically Vichy was uh control the
Japanese meta what games gets played
right mobas they do not like in Japan no
yeah okay that's Korea yeah Korea yeah
yeah yeah does not want mobiles are you
playing any games outside of uh
like fortnite and uh yeah what games do
you play internally you know what's
crazy it's gonna sound crazy but it's
actually fortnite
it's okay I I played TFT and that's like
the most cringe game of all oh actually
you know what I've started playing a bit
uh Super Auto pets actually casually
that is kind of like TFT yeah it is
that one's yeah surprisingly fun to play
uh yeah with friends as well we used to
play the DOTA one the DOTA chess and
then I just that was the first Auto Show
yeah that was yeah yeah and then like
yoink and then yeah it's always funny
how those happened
um but yeah no honestly it's like I'll
probably wake up and still like get in
at least a game of fortnite right I'm
probably addicted to fortnite right like
and I don't even make much content on
anymore it's just like some habitually
ingrained in me for five years of making
content on the game because a lot of
times in that journey of like making
content when I was daily uploading and
stuff it would be let's just play to
figure out what to record and like what
can I like let's let's on the Fly here
make someone while playing a game yeah
and then that just became a habit to
just play a game every day and it's like
well I I think the big thing about
getting into a new competitive game is
that when you put so much time into like
learning the mechanics of one game it's
really hard to just jump into you like
jump into another game casually and be
like I want to spend time learning this
game now right because that's why I will
never play another MOBA outside of
League because like I there was a time
when I enjoyed League of Legends I spent
God knows how many hours just learning
the basic [__] how like just how to
play the game yeah how the game works
and I do not have that time in my life
anymore yeah you know sure sure yeah is
there any like if you could pick any
games that you would want power to like
kind of like be represented in like yeah
regardless of like Logistics yeah
regardless of logistics I mean we wanted
to do we wanted to do valorant we were
looking at that pretty heavily then they
went franchised right which yeah what
does that mean when they get franchise
uh essentially it was like kind of like
invite only and we weren't in it yet so
it kind of made sense like but they
didn't pick any Australian teams in the
franchise model there's no yeah there
was gonna be one and then they went
bankrupt
um welcome to Esports
everybody's going Bang
we'll see LG recently announced yeah
darling back and then God fired all of
their employees yeah and then I think V1
was talking about looking for a merger I
think I saw her like
saw TSM down back or something like that
would you like if TSM is dialing back
that's pretty scary for the whole
industry because that's like one of the
biggest brand name orgs yeah yeah
exactly
um so I'm guessing I'm guessing being an
Australian Esports team you guys are
always seen as The Underdogs yeah and
actually I love it because when we win
it's gonna feel so [__] good like and
that's why you gotta get behind us
to win right like
an Aussie Spirits Underdog like yeah
that is it how much do you think crappy
Australian internet has played a role in
their weekend yeah because I was gonna
ask it's definitely part of it like
we'll still get Rocket League games and
it's like guys drop down it's like oh
yeah internet like yeah like and there's
like a little like I think we have a
higher
I could be wrong but I think there's
like a we take more referee pauses like
in any other region in rlcs because it's
like yeah internet like it's just a
common thing especially when people
playing out rural it's like yeah okay
he's gonna say out like will he come
back uh coin flip we don't know yeah
yeah
um definitely definitely a pot and I
would say even YouTube as well like
early on I had to get my video done by 8
PM so that I could upload it overnight
yeah I was there as well yeah yeah I I I
because when I was living in Australia
making content I was also uploading
daily yeah and uh there'd be like an off
peak and then there'll be an on-peak and
if you didn't upload during the uh or if
you uploaded during the on Peak then by
the end of the month your internet was
just [__] yeah because there's always
a cap to it so you had what yeah so how
it works yeah oh we were broken for sure
yeah yeah so basically is notoriously
bad yeah so basically how it worked was
that I think it's like between like uh
12 a.m and when was it it was like for
me I think I started at 10 p.m yeah it
was like it was basically it was like 10
10 P.M M ish that would be an off peak
which is basically it's basically like
you're separating the data cap into two
halves one during the day and one during
the night and if you exhausted it during
one of the Peaks then the other Peak
would be affected yes but your internet
would just go down to dial-up speed
until it would refresh the next month
and so when I was uploading so I went so
when I was uploading daily I had to
basically upload it overnight because
not only was the internet so incredibly
[__] so that it took all night time
yeah yeah but also if I did it during
the day then I would exhaust the peak
and then my dad would come into my room
pissed off as [__] me like why is my
internet at dial up speed because you
uploaded all this [__] and basically
capped out our data yeah and you lived
in Sydney so you weren't like in the
middle of [__] nowhere dude I had
point three uploads were you in the city
uh I was just outside of the city I was
in Northern Beach because apparently for
like the the way they like refresh the
internet is for some places they started
outside then in the city like they
didn't start from the the city and then
go out they went out from the suburbs
into the city I think Melbourne's like
that from whatever right where like
people in Melbourne still in the city
kind of have [__] in that uh yeah no I
don't I don't think it was like that for
us I think it was just kind of in Sydney
it was just like a like overnight
everyone would just like get a refreshed
yeah uh but either way like I had to
basically like really down scale my
videos to make the files as small as
possible one because it would take a
billion years to upload so that I
wouldn't be able to make the daily
upload schedule but two if I was
uploading like a gigabyte video files
every single day dude my internet would
be out in like the first 10 days yeah
and then I'd have dial up for the next
20 days which is just like when I first
got an edited horrendous I started
uploading the raw footage and that's
when I realized oh [__] my internet is
so slow yeah it's a YouTube video you
know you you'd render it and it would
come out yeah and it's 1080P and it made
me come out to like 700 megabytes yeah
gigabyte tops right right but then when
you start learning raw footage and then
you know this raw footage is three hours
long and there's two camera angles like
oh this is gonna take four days yeah so
I couldn't upload 1080p videos while I
was living in Australia because the
files were too big yeah so the first two
and a half years I was uploading 720p at
most and I was using like a program to
like basically scale it down yeah it's a
sacrifice like graphical quality or like
audio quality just so I could upload it
without going over my cast crazy yeah
and that was fun and then you know by
the time I moved out to Australia
because my PC was basically on 24 hours
for two and a half years straight uh it
exploded one day and it like actually
burst into flames and I was like well
guess I'm moving to Japan now wow that's
the catalog you take it for granted in
Japan though how how lucky you are to
have oh yeah yeah high speeds everywhere
because you're you haven't seen speeds
even through like mobile connections
yeah and there's no cap either yeah
there's no cap yeah yeah I upload like a
terabyte of files I'm like all right
I'll be dumb by dinner time yeah
yeah that's crazy is uh is the
Australian isn't that still bad it's not
bad now like I've you there's like a
couple good providers now and like
they've got ambient infrastructure in
most places the national Broadband
Network yeah yeah which was yeah Harry
for a while there but it's good now it's
yeah not terabytes but like you know we
do a couple gigabytes nice yes hell yeah
how's the pink in Australian like
competitive games because like it's it's
like a meme the league Community where
everyone's trying to figure out why n a
like North America sucks so bad and
there's like a million different like
[__] excuses one of them is just like
oh it's because of the pigs like because
the servers are like in the middle of
America yeah the servers are in the
middle of America and they're all like
all in California L.A so it's like yeah
the pro players can't get like good
practice so what happened like 60 ping
right 60 Ms that's kind of have a lot
yeah that's I think a lot of people do
play on like 60. yeah yeah I think in
Korea it's like three or something right
it's like it's like 10 or below 10 in
Korea yeah yeah I think I get like 15 in
Tokyo when I was in Australia and like
before the national Broadband Network
came out and I was playing like Gmod
with like a bunch of my friends in
America like I had like 300 on a good
day yeah yeah well that was like yeah
because during my early days doing
Minecraft like 2014 like I was recording
with
Americans yeah I was the only Aussie and
I was like it was the meme of like me
being like flying around yeah
this like yeah they call me like the
blur because I would be blurring just
talking through everything but yeah I
mean it was good fun waking up at bad
hours
um it's good it was grind days for sure
yeah but like how how bad is like the
Ping now when it comes oh yeah facing
kind of like a competitive scene here in
Australia yes that's not bad so all the
servers based in Sydney
um right yeah so we might like we did
that one thing where we flew our players
down to Sydney and played some games out
there to have zero pain because in
fortnite ping is essential for taking
their walls so you'd pickaxe the wall
and it would be like who places it first
next and it's who's ever closest to the
server right yeah they said they added
spamming it right yeah you're both
spamming it and it's like they say it's
a coin flip on like a 50 50 chance but
if your ping is good enough it doesn't
do the coin slip and you just get it
yeah right um and like that's a big key
mechanical like fighting because if you
take the wall you can edit and then get
a free shot yeah right so that's like if
you build the wall in fortnite you can
actually like this because it's a three
by three you can actually like press a
button that allows you to remove parts
of the wall yeah so you can imagine it
right if you have a if you've boxed
someone in and you're the one who built
the wall you can quickly you know
exactly when you're going to remove a
section of this wall then you can just
shoot through it ah so like I could just
remove a portion to shoot them and then
put it back oh wow yeah yeah so that's I
can't do anything oh yeah they just sit
there and take it yeah um so that's why
yeah so I guess ping is a big factor I
didn't know that was a big deal yeah so
that's like uh like in America right now
they even just did it with um fortnite
where they had the e-servers and the
West servers and they just randomly like
hey it's all going Central so like all
these guys have set up boot camps on
East Coast because that was the biggest
dominant competitive scene and I've all
just moved to Texas
Jesus Christ it's crazy to think that
like so much infrastructure that's
already built could just be overturned
by where they're like yeah I'm gonna
move the server yeah yeah it's kind of
insane to think no it's wild it's wild
yeah I mean like I I don't know how
big kind of like Esports plays a factor
into business decisions that they make
yeah I can't imagine it plays like the
biggest Factor you know for America I
think it yeah definitely would be like
we think about it for religious it's
kind of like um the Apex teams in
Australia are actually I know I said
before that you know Australian teams go
International they don't win the Apex
teams and I actually got to meet uh Jen
Burch and uh Jen Burton I think his name
is
um in a tournament I did last week so
he's actually a part of the elusive
Australians that go overseas and win
right they won a couple of the
international Apex tournaments uh last
year and so they will qualify through
Asia play against Japanese teams yeah
and actually win on like 160 ping like
games wow because the game's got good
enough net code that like and I
experience it's really not hard to play
on bad ping yeah it's actually very good
for it like I played the whole
tournament 200 ping and it felt fine
it's like OverWatch is like that
OverWatch when I played it I noticed
that the Ping didn't feel that bad like
other games like uh Valerian you're like
I'm I die now yeah I thought that's
horrible for high ping as well yeah
right right but yeah no so like they'll
play on 160 and win which I think is
that's pretty cool science yeah like
before what you mentioned before uh have
you ever competed yourself in any other
tournaments
just just the Fortnight stuff I think
was right I was gonna do a Pokemon go uh
tournament earlier this year just for a
meme for a little throwback meme because
they've actually got like a competitive
aspect to that now could you be
competitive in Pokemon go oh because you
can you can battle each other now yeah I
actually ironically play I I stopped
playing I think about a year or so ago
yeah yeah like in the middle of the
pandemic like yeah when the pandemic
started I was like well I can't go
outside so I can't really play it
independent must have murdered Pokemon
yeah they I don't know what they did
they did something that allowed you to
go to pokestops without physically being
there yeah I think so it does not remove
the whole point of Pokemon go yeah but
no one could go outside yeah so they had
to do they had to do something whatever
the name just died but I remember when I
was still playing it they introduced
like uh yeah basically like a battle
system where like you could pick like
three Pokemon right and then based on
your uh was it uh what was the power of
scaling called in Pokemon go again it
was like the points or whatever CP right
that's it yeah yeah which is the worst
yeah
so it's like it's like you you're taking
three Pokemon and then your CP would
actually just account I think for like
the HP or something and then you
basically just like battle it out to see
you know who gets off screen yeah tap
the screen you know like yeah it has
competitive things it's like it's like
the it's like the VGC game it's like
right kind of random but kind of skill
like you know this could work or what
moves are they running is like the
biggest competitive depth there's not
much competitive depth to it at all
which is why I thought I could actually
walk in there maybe do something yeah
yeah
you I think you could because you could
just yeah you just look up your kind of
what the two lists are online and just
go with something like that that makes
sense but no I didn't nah didn't manage
to get that done but no not not really
involved anything else outside of
fortnite that's just you you must have
traveled quite a lot during like your
Pokemon go content phase then yes yeah
we caught all the Regionals right all
the ones he had to go like America and
Japan for oh my God because you made
content doing that being like I'm gonna
go on a flight now to go and get a
Pokemon go from Japan 100. that's the
whole that's what's taking me what was
it was like far-fetched you could only
catch in Japan that's it yeah it was the
European one was it Taurus or Mr mime
and Kangaskhan was Australia yeah yeah
so I did did a bit of traveling there
yeah did did all of them did your
Around the World in 80 Days funded by
Pokemon go right well it's actually even
better because I think I almost like
Gamescom so it was like and I was with
there with the EA playing Battlefield so
I was like I was doing that and then
doing this as well right um because
they're still running a second Channel
playing other games okay but uh yeah no
lots of lots of traveling and how many
countries did you end up pinning up the
order for Pokemon go
can you even remember I can't honestly
it's gonna be at least it's gonna be at
least six I reckon okay yeah America
Canada Japan I mean do we count
Australia not really I'm Already There
Germany UK and then there was some I
think Dubai as well what do you think of
the UK yeah I actually really like the
UK yeah that's that's a whole take yeah
I like the people there what are you
talking about okay we're talking people
ranking I would say and I think it's
because people right let's break for you
okay that's fine
so I feel like because like bless up the
queen like Australia Canada and UK
people like just gel the most yeah like
yeah I get on with everybody like I
lived in Canada for like about a year
everyone there super friendly super nice
yeah yeah uh UK feels like Sydney in
some aspects yeah it feels like City but
worse like yes so very
[Music]
with the sidemen
um and like they're always up to some
crazy mad [__] like they've been on a
run for a long time so it's always good
to hang out with those guys like I
honestly just have a lot of fun when I
go to the UK I guess yeah yeah I mean UK
and Australia is very close culturally I
would say especially local people uh and
I'm just like every time I meet on
Australian uh and go to Australia I was
like oh this is what the UK could be
like if we were happy
unlike to me like Australia British
people are like a step like if we're
tearing the tier list it's like British
people stepped down from Australians
because they're just less happy okay but
what who's asked here in this who's
Esther
ing people yeah yeah I think it's just
tearing a nationality
oh God is that racist
so I can only do white cats
well then amongst the white countries
it's like it's like to me as a Southeast
Asian I'm like my like I've seen so much
like similarities where hang out with
like Latin America people it's like it's
like you know Aussies UK New Zealand
Canada they all jail well I feel like
Southeast Asian and Latin America people
yeah it's just like yeah yeah also it
fits like a glove as well sure
um yeah I don't know what else though
yeah what about your Japanese side who'd
you get along the most with as uh from
you like your Japanese side uh well
considering how xenophobic we are we
only really hang out with Japanese
people
because like everybody else is there
according to Japan
yeah yeah but actually you've actually
been to Japan right yeah yeah so uh I
lived in uh now here's the thing I think
I was talking to you last night but I
say Osaka yeah but you say it I thought
he said Osaka yeah I was like I I think
I might have just in the accident the
way I say it and I'm like and I'm like
what you used to be where our old Studio
was in saitama and then and the local
was like what side yeah
you said yeah no yes I was in Osaka for
it doesn't sound like you're saying yeah
yeah so what wait what's up why why also
um so at the time like uh the girl I was
dating she got a job out there and I was
like I can do this anywhere I can make
content anywhere
um and I love Japan the few times I went
for Pokemon I was like absolutely just
loved it so I was like yeah I could do
this so got one of those visas that
allowed me like a working holiday for a
year and then just moved over I got an
Airbnb and
set up a computer upstairs in this
little concrete castle and then
off we go how's it recording
YouTube videos with in a presumably a
small Japanese apartment with neighbors
and stuff how was that yeah I didn't get
any noise compliances you didn't I
didn't I'd like to think it was very
soundproof like concrete I don't know
this is it though you're right because I
was very conscious of that I did not
want to be that guy coming in just
shouting playing fortnite yeah yeah
because that's what I was doing
um just doing the streaming thing at the
time as well so it was kind of just get
hours in
um but no man that was like that was so
much fun and then that got cut short
because of covert I was like I gotta go
back home I gotta so how long were you
there for that I was only there for I
think two and a half three months oh wow
yeah yeah and I was meant to be there
for a full year and I got cut short and
now I can't get that Visa again how's
your how's your experience in Japan I
loved it man it was so much fun like
just getting to like explore different
towns like every weekend like yeah even
just running around Osaka and just
finding all these new different places
soccer is great as well because like
unlike people in Tokyo I feel just like
people in Osaka just like very a lot
more like stranger friendly yeah like
they're a lot more comfortable I think
like not just with foreigners but just
like with people they don't know yeah
and just like a lot more like open like
if you go up to someone in Osaka and
just like start chatting with them more
times than in Tokyo they're just like
yeah okay I'll engage in this
conversation you know [__] have a bit
of beer yeah a lot less English though
and for me you wouldn't really still
don't really speak Japanese yeah
um did you did you end up picking up any
Japanese at all like just enough to get
by you know we ran Google Translate for
the most but like you know like uh you
know yarigato yeah
that's all you need to know yeah pretty
much that's pretty much saying is the
the thing you say the most yes it really
is it really is I forgot them everything
yeah I heard you had a had a famous uh
had a favorite Ramen joint okay so we're
talking about this in the break we got
this so this is the the trash tank I
guess is that ichiron is actually good
yeah yeah it's actually good yeah these
guys are these guys people in Japan love
it they go crazy no it's like the most
mid-rise
it's good why do you think it's so
popular in Japan it's not just tourists
it's really really popular because Japan
because Japanese people will [__]
form a line on any mediocrity if it's
sold well enough wow they will like
there's so many like there's so many
places where it's like why is there a
line forming in front of this thing that
the common understanding is that it's
kind of mid as hell like at our old
office right we had we had a Burger King
like right near our station okay there
was a line forming okay the [__]
Burger King because there was a new
burger that was coming out and I'm like
what well Japanese people just like line
up for anything that's new yeah yeah I
remember seeing like several lines
outside of McDonald's as well several
times I would like I was gonna say I
really liked Japanese McDonald's
Japanese McDonald's is good Japanese
McDonald's is good but it's not
something I'd be like
everything
I'm lining up for McDonald's there are
very few things I would like line up for
because I don't know like maybe it's
like when I've been getting older but if
I'm hungry I I just want food like now
yeah I I don't like lining up yeah I
don't like lining up there's like have
you seen those tick tocks whatever
they're like this is the best onigiri
place in Japan and it's like a two-hour
line for a [__] onigiri that's what
I'm saying like Japanese what is it oh
it's a rice rice ball oh people will
line up two hours just to get a [__]
Rice Bowl yeah like recently there's
been this boom in Japan of uh like
onigiri like specific uh like places
yeah and they're supposedly it's like oh
it's it's a there's a different type of
rice bowl like we specialize in rice
balls I'm like how much can you change
this yeah it's good uh but like that's
the thing is like I feel Japan is is
this has this common idea where it's
like they see a line or they see a crowd
and the first instinct is oh I should
probably join in on it because it's
probably something that a I don't want
to miss out on or B is something really
good because it's like it must be good
if there's a line in front of it yeah
but then there's this kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy of like well
even the people are just lining up
because the line is there like they're
not actually thinking about well is it
actually good or if is the product even
worth lining up for and I feel ichiran
is a big culprit in that because ichiran
and a lot of these like big chains do
this thing where they just like make the
outside look flashy as [__] yeah to be
like hey we have great Ramen just you
know blasting it out into the
stratosphere and the Japanese people
look at it and be like well that looks
kind of sick start lining up and then
the line forms I think one of the things
that ichudan has done if you I mean you
can use Google pictures of it um you
know ramen places are traditionally very
like dingy yeah kind of like it's
definitely yeah it's due to smell of
smoke you know it's not like them you
know and when you walk in and you look
white as [__] it's just like they're
like they're all just like
yeah yeah like yeah there's a few things
that ichiron does well especially if
you're a tourist which is why I think
it's so popular it's one uh like you can
it's it's so easy to order there's no
kind of like barrier to be like Oh I'm
going to this also like made for
Japanese people they don't want to talk
okay yeah yeah exactly exactly well most
ramen places they just have you know
little vending machine where you can get
tickets and then you just give it to the
dude right but even like yeah even like
trying to I guess trying to figure out
the ticket machine is kind of like
daunting if you've never been to Japan
before you don't know how it works the
one I feel the one thing that each run
did really really well was that like
they're the one of the best when it
comes to like customizing yeah that's it
I always want to add like 10 more cloves
of garlic and it's true and you can just
add a [__] ton of garlic yeah like they
give you that option so that's like the
big selling point of ramen but I'm like
just because the options for
customizability is there doesn't mean
it's good I love it I think it tastes
[__] bombs yeah I I tried to hit it
like at least once a week when I was in
football
I remember like I would finish the
street because 24 hours as well at least
one mine was 24 hours yeah
um but it was like hit like a four or
five hour stream it was like it was
winter too when I was there like early
in the year yeah oh 100 I was like just
just bang like a five hour stream it's 2
A.M I'm going out it's your own and I
got my bike bike down each run and I
think it was in a bit of a interesting
place because a lot of guys in suits you
right yes
but it was like I should probably not be
here I I don't know I I was like it was
a bit Saucy like because it was in this
District where I think also like the
strip clubs were as well yeah yeah and
it was like just a lot of guys in suits
like on the what are they they were like
in on the corner of the intersection
like the touts they're like they're
trying to get you into places yeah but
it was just weird also I think I know
the area you're talking about and I
guarantee the majority of those dudes in
suits were probably Yakuza members
and there we go yeah and I'm just
walking through white guy on a bike 2AM
going to get some itchy on yeah yeah I I
I was thinking maybe it might be
something going on here but like you
know I just
my equivalent of I guess going to Japan
and going to like ichiran for me would
be like going to America and going to
McDonald's you know it's kind of like
you go to a country where there's so
much great choice of [__] burgers and
fast food and you choose McDonald's so
so in Japan this is kind of anomaly
where like reviews of places are pretty
consistently around the same score but
for ramen they're always lower like
consistently they a four-star Ramen
place is quite uncommon on Google Maps
but they'll always be four star like
other restaurants right and so
and I realized I'm like yeah because a
lot of Rama placing Transit [__] suck
like sometimes they'll give you the
chashu the pork yeah and it's just the
worst piece of meat I've ever had in my
life it's gross it's fatty it doesn't
taste of anything and I'm like dude it's
sure never [__] this up yeah because
they've been around for so long that
they've like able to engineer it
perfectly this is how chains come around
ramen shops in Japan are like some of
the fastest some of them are good some
of them are good some of them I like the
ones some of them some of the men I
don't know what they've done of that
pork I thought they abused it before
they killed it the ramen shops in
general in Japan are like the the most
competitive scene yeah yeah Japan like a
Ramen Shop could be there and then like
a month later it'd be gone well it's
because the margins are so low like
you're selling a bowl of ramen for like
you know you can't sell all wrong with
more than 1200 313 uh 1300 Yen yeah
because no one does that no that doesn't
give you a lot of time to make money all
right important question though what's
what's the best combini what was your
convenience store of choice uh okay I
started with 7-Eleven but I think I got
converted to Lawson yes okay okay I feel
like all the numbers they start 7-Eleven
and it's like okay yeah the Fried
Chicken's good like and I was right next
to the 7-Eleven as well like I had walk
out my door two minute walk 7-Eleven
yeah so like I'd definitely still go
there for like the easy ones but if I
could make it to Lawson there's an extra
like five minute walk I always walk
there yeah distance or drive the extra
mile for the Lawsons because it's just
so much better yeah the coffee's decent
the the food they have the sandwiches
those hot Bento things with the katsu
things so good it's they don't mess
Lawson's really up the game yeah yeah
and they're like they're snacks and
they're like own brand snacks yeah
they're so much better awesome branded
stuff yeah that's so good it's really
good the thing I noticed last 7-Eleven
has like one or two like good food
pieces I think yeah just that's it and
everything else is just overshadowed
there's a lot of sadness all my homies
hate family marks and they're everywhere
actually only the real ones they run
Tokyo as well you're just in my area
which was none yeah yeah yeah I don't
know it's so weird it pains me whenever
someone goes to uh Japan and they were
like I got some family my chicken and I
[__] loved it
I'm calling you out Chris because I've
got no questions converted to Lawson's I
see okay okay it only took him 10 years
he was telling me that apparently like
10 years ago like Lawson's just wasn't
that good and it was pretty bad and then
they had like a massive revamp like five
six years ago yeah it kind of root just
were like we're redoing everything yo
season two Lawson yeah [__] slap they
just like they just like up the game and
then like now like they collaborate with
like Muji which is a Japanese kind of
like kind of Ikea but more minimalist
yeah yeah they just have all of like
they're really nice stuff in their
stores like it's really nice food also
slaps do yeah everything have they're so
good yeah yeah what else did you enjoy
about Japan when you were living there
oh geez oh wait I mean we did a stint in
Kyoto for like a couple weeks we're
actually all week but that was like
beautiful
um
was there a lot of tourist back back
when you were living there ah
ah I did not see many in Osaka I did not
see many at all like no I went the other
week and they were so God damn well I've
heard now like post covered all of Japan
is just yeah yeah like yeah it's fine
going crazy right now
um which makes sense like couldn't go
for so long and everybody I felt like
had this kind of like I want to travel
and I think Japan is it for everyone
yeah yeah yeah myself included what was
your biggest uh culture shock when you
got there
like what was the one thing where you're
like whoa Japan is epic that's oh that's
a question it was the vending machines
honestly it was just how good the trains
were
oh my God our public transport is oh my
God yeah yeah [__] no like they they so
efficient yeah and I think I remember
once I was in there in the morning like
6 a.m and it was like everybody going to
work and it was like a stampede of like
workers oh yeah seriously it was
actually like dystopian yeah
like in unison they were walking almost
like like an army like just yeah through
these train stations like that was crazy
um that like that because that was my
first you know kind of experience with
trains and then like figuring out how it
works and once you work it out you're
like wow this is soul fishing it's so
great like color go here yeah literally
this color yeah no it makes sense
um I'm I'm curious because you know you
mentioned that your trip got cut short
uh and obviously you were only there for
two and a half months but you must have
moved there maybe when covered murmurs
were kind of already beginning yeah so
what was that kind of like that two
months of like monitoring lived there
the same time that we moved there
actually yeah that's we moved there like
three months before covered here
actually we moved we moved in October
and then covid lockdown officially kind
of started late April Yeah March April I
think I left February late February so
it must have been roughly the same time
yeah at the same time I traveled to
America in February of covid and that
was when they started asking like it
wasn't it wasn't everywhere yet there
was a few cases dotted around but they
were like oh have you been to China in
the past 14 days yeah you're like no no
why maybe like no reason
yeah no like I was definitely like every
day like I think everybody was right
like especially like being in Asia when
it you know originated in China it was
like yeah kind of like you know my
family were like well I I don't know
people didn't know anything yeah well
you didn't know everything and you've
seen all these articles and it's like
well I don't know how to believe this
guy that guy is a count on a sheet
somewhere going up every day like what's
the count today yeah I don't know it was
just kind of like I felt like I could
have got stuck there forever and maybe
like I think for you guys it sounded
like it was all right
worked out for us
if you'd have stayed you probably would
have been stuck there for the yeah 100
yeah a full year and like I didn't know
if I was Keen to do that
um because like I liked where I lived
but like I lost all the luxuries so I
different yeah no there's like because
it was Winter and I was in this like I'm
not kidding concrete Castle so like it
was cold as [__] so like he's gonna have
AC or heating it had heating but then
you get like super dry like so I tried
not to use it and I tried to have all
these like uh I'd use it in combination
with like an air uh or
umidifiers were stupid until I moved to
Japan yeah I've never had one before
yeah yeah seriously
um but yeah like I I I I missed my space
because yeah you don't get you don't you
don't get the space in Japan and I was
pretty Central to Osaka as well so like
I was really not getting a lot of space
yeah
um but yeah I was just like I don't know
if I could do this
right right eight ten months plus like
yeah it's I wasn't trying to be in a
pandemic in a country where I don't
speak the language like yeah yeah how
did you find like the uh nightlife there
because Osaka has a pretty like
Good Night Live scene yeah no uh we went
out pretty like no not too often but
like we definitely had like good
connections so like where my uh
girlfriend was working at the time she
had like connections with uh the the
some of the nightclubs running there and
so we'd go out and I actually became
really good friends with one of the
promoters at a couple of clubs oh wow
show us all these different clubs and no
it was a good time it was really good
time I'm gonna hit him up when I go back
yeah no
um yeah shout out my boy Mike
um but yeah no I I don't know do you
what did you guys like experience going
out like I know I've heard a couple bits
of you talking about like getting
rejected at certain places and stuff
some places don't want you yeah yeah
nothing like insane
um I mean we normally just go to bars
yeah we're not we're not big in a club
initially we when we moved there we
tried to go to like the local uh
izakayas and stuff like that and then
eventually we were just like I think I
think I just like bars now you know yeah
yeah I'm definitely in that bar scene
now like even if I have to shout to talk
to you it's not fun for anyone yeah no
it just like every time I have to shout
out to me myself like I feel like as a
part of my lifespan just like decrease
because I know I have to do it but every
day I haven't gotten used to it yet yeah
so did you get to try a lot of like new
Japanese foods like that okay so there's
like the normal like mainstream kind of
like Ramen Sushi did you manage to try
like any other like Cuisines that aren't
as like popular so I tried one of those
like expensive Kobe beef experiences oh
yeah of course all right now where are
they so they overrated under it where
are we doing okay is Kobe beef overrated
yes okay I can tell you that I I think
it is yeah I think it is it's great but
it's like it's kind of a one-off thing
because it's super fatty yeah yeah it's
really rich and really heavy it's like a
once or twice a year thing yeah I still
prefer a normal steak like yeah normal
steak for me is still better than great
wagyu beef beef is I mean it doesn't
even taste the same mistake no it
doesn't yeah no it's fat yeah it's fat
with a bit of meat in it but like I had
one of those ones where it's like you
sit down and they've got the butter yeah
yeah and they do that with the Kobe and
it was like okay this is kind of a Vibe
yeah I did that and Kobe recently and it
was I mean it was pretty [__] good
yeah you guys would have done a few like
sure because you guys do like the
Japanese travel video like yeah type
things like sure you've done a few
stints yeah I mean not even not even
just filming it just you know trying out
the experience because of course you you
have to you know
um and I remember when I did it uh they
they had like the option of just like
you know the amount of beef but you
could order an extra large portion as
well and I'm like yeah I'm getting like
the top tier beef man I gotta get the
extra large portion yeah and uh and I
remember having like half of it and that
half was like the perfect amount that
was like every bite was like Godly you
see the fat
um and then we got to the extra portion
and it just it was just too much yeah
like it started going from tasting like
Godly to like this is I actually feel
sick now yeah I had I made that mistake
when the first time I had the uh Olive
wagyu oh that's crazy it's more white
than pink yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's
like the first like two or three bites
was just like oh my God I'm about to not
and then and then the second half I'm
just like I'm just like drinking olive
oil it's just like I could feel my like
paws just clogging up this is where I
like Teppanyaki like a traditional
Teppanyaki is the best way to do it
because you'll have like a full course
meal of like uh other stuff like veg
fish yeah yeah all done on this thing
and then you'll have one course of like
all right we'll give you a little bit of
like maybe fatty beef or whatever like I
understand why the portions are so small
now yeah well that is the optimal amount
yeah the only problem is that it's like
[__] two to three hundred dollars
also yeah it is so expensive but if if
you you have a little bit of money
definitely recommend doing it yeah yeah
no it was something what did you think
of it no it was it was awesome but my
question to you guys have you guys done
the the the the puffer fish uh what's it
called yeah that is that that's
overrated okay no but like what's about
I've heard like a little sensation in
your mouth like oh obviously you can
blend when I had it yeah nothing it just
the problem is is that like because one
there's no flavor and two like unlike a
lot of other Sushi where you know it's
you can like chew it through it and it's
fine for some reason puff fish is like
it's really incredibly chewy so they
have to cut this thing like paper thin
yeah right because any thicker and
you'll just be it's like chewing gum
yeah wow that's not what you want and
it's like it's like prohibitively
expensive there's like a one in like 10
000 chance you can die from eating it as
well and I'm just like is it worth it
sounds like that's that just sounds it's
all just whatever you buy humans for
just hearing it's poisonous and just
being like we can find a way
we got it yeah
what if we even get yeah like surely
people had to die multiple times before
they were like we let's come on
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like we could
just stick to no we're doing this yeah
we've decided if I had to pick the most
overrated Japanese food it would
actually be puffer fish yeah because it
tastes like [__] it it's the only taste
you get is the taste of like the soy
sauce
um and you ate basically just eat it for
the danger you know maybe a
controversial opinion here I think Ramen
in Japan is it's good but I also think
it's pretty good outside of Japan now
like I don't think it's necessarily much
better in Japan compared to like some
nice places you're getting some good
ramen Wales not whales yeah I think I
think if you pay enough money yeah like
the more like I guess like not luxury
but like expensive ramen places outside
of Japan I think have gotten to the
point where it's pretty difficult to
differentiate between like one made in
Japan one made outside of Japan but the
advantage that Japanese ramen has is
that is the price Factor yeah because
it's like for sure if you buy like a 10
Ramen in Japan nine times out of ten
it's pretty [__] good right if you
buy a 10 Ramen outside of Japan no that
was one time out of ten yeah yeah yeah
there's like a bunch like when I was in
Vancouver they have so many actual just
Japanese like uh like they're sorry like
a Japanese like uh Vancouver counterpart
to a Japanese restaurant that exists
yeah yeah so I had like Hokkaido Ramen
in Vancouver that tasted just like it
would in Japan well I think it
definitely much as well that like yeah
has such a high like Asian population
yeah yeah I think that's the demand is I
think that's less to do with Japan and
more to do with just Vancouver being
like uh having an amazing yeah culture
yeah I think that the point I was gonna
try and get at is that like I don't
think if you're coming to Japan you only
got like a week I don't think you need
to get Ramen I think there's a lot of
other stuff that you just cannot get
outside of Japan yes like unagi I've
never seen outside of Japan
uh yeah I had it yeah it's like smoked
and then grilled and coated with this
really nice like sauce yes kind of like
barbecue kind of sauce yeah I had it I
was freaking out because I'm like [__]
man I don't want to eat it
was it was better than I thought it
would be oh yeah yeah I feel outside of
Japan eel just has this like weird thing
yeah I would like I'm not [__] eating
anything
I would not eat I think Japan eats like
half of the world's eels or something
crazy yeah yeah I might have been I made
that the [__] up
chain amount that Japan eats like a good
chunk of the world's percentage of eels
yeah like it's like almost impressive
because that's actually managed to make
it good yeah and they're 100 of the food
the British tried it and we were just
like let's just put in [__] jelly in
it yeah
that's so disgusting I still want to try
that oh no no you don't I just want to
see how bad it is it comes to [__]
pie they just put your pie on the side
like it can't be good if you come to the
pie on the side if I'd say one Japanese
food that I think you shouldn't need to
try if you come to Japan uh Japanese
Curry
oh yeah I've had so many outside of
Japan yeah I I think Japanese Curry
tastes like the same everywhere I think
so and yeah it's pretty easy to
replicate yeah yeah it is like it's it's
one that is of like it's a nice comfort
food there is a place there's a place
where I'm like [__] yes give me some
Japanese Curry but holy [__] if I I've
said it I've said some outrageous things
about things tasting the same over my
years in trash taste but I do generally
think that Japanese Curry does taste the
same no matter where you are in the
world because it's so easy right yeah
like it's the simplest one to make like
it's like just you know just straight up
just the most standardized Curry that
you can get out of all the different
types of cards home blocks where you
just snap a block yeah yeah yeah yeah
have Curry and yeah you know Coco Ichi
as well especially is like almost
everywhere now at this point and it
really does just like taste the same
everywhere yeah the cauliflower rice is
pretty good cauliflower rice they do
like if you don't want the carbs you can
just get shredded cauliflower that's
right it's pretty good yeah yeah I don't
feel as guilty yeah
have you guys seen the
um I've saw it on Tick Tock the other
week it was like these Frozen Ramen
packs you can get and apparently it's
meant to be like restaurant quality and
like that's what I'm saying I'm saying
if you go to Lawson's or anything yeah
and you have Ramen it's frozen yeah and
so that when you when you put it in the
microwave for like five minutes yeah
when you're heating up the oil again it
like dissolves and then boils again yeah
yeah and it is decent it's fine
Ramen but it's nowhere near
[Music]
yeah really I've never tried them I was
wondering if you guys have but yeah you
have I used to live off them for like
two weeks whatever yeah yeah kind of
like that's a weave diet right there
yeah yeah it's funny because I kind of
like got off Ramen after I moved to
Japan which was super bad for you yeah
yeah it's horrible yeah yeah it's so
much because I'd realize after every
time I'd have like a big Ramen it would
just like kind of like knock me out for
a few hours because it's not one of
those meals where you can just have a
nice Ramen it's it's one and just like
move on it's just like after you have a
Ramen you just you need to just sit down
for a second bloated yes digest yeah you
know you know yeah so I actually like
have not had much Ramen since I've moved
to Japan I've actually like sushi I have
sushi quite a lot though yeah so Sushi
has not gone down oh yeah of course what
would you guys think is like traditional
for like Australian like what's what's
the Australian Cuisine soul food kind of
here uh chicken Palm maybe yeah
how the hell the chicken palmy like
become a staple of Australian Cuisine I
think it's just it's really hard to hate
chicken cheese and marinara you know
it's just like it's like the classic
like Pub feed and like that's yeah beans
and toast about us and you have just
[__] chicken with cheese yeah like
that's like well I mean you know there's
a lot of Aussies who eat you know like
beans and and toast do you yeah I used
to have that for breakfast yeah it's a
safer like breakfast food here yeah yeah
yeah like egg or cheese on it too and
egg and fancy that's way too fancy
Australian the thing with Australian
Cuisine is that it's like it's three
ingredients Max yeah you know it's like
oh we we could have you know like we
could get really fancy with Avo on toast
but why not just have Avo and toast and
that's it maybe a little crack salt and
pepper maybe yeah maybe if you're
feeling fancy yeah and that's good
I guess like uh like uh what's what's
the fish that we have here that
barramundi yeah barramundi yeah that's
okay that's like a that's like a pretty
staple like Pub feed here oh yeah yeah
it's pretty good that's pretty good I've
not tried that yeah like a barramundi uh
like burger or like even just like you
can get all sorts of like rare money in
like pubs and stuff like that it's
pretty [__] Coffee Culture here is my
favorite yeah I know yeah especially
here yeah it goes so hot here I remember
the first time going to America getting
coffee and be like what the [__] is
like I met like Starbucks is this
massive conglomerate comedy I'm just
like they're just serving the worst
coffee you don't wanna you don't want to
have coffee in Japan wait I thought it
was right I think Starbucks in Japan was
actually all right yeah
which is like yeah anywhere outside of
Starbucks and [__] well no there's some
like because what is it coffee's on the
waves right so coffee's on Wave there's
like the wave three which is like the
season three well it's like it's like
yeah it's like it's like the minimalist
coffee right yeah you go in it's all
concrete wood and then those kind of
places are normally pretty decent
because they're all espresso based and I
feel it's a gamble though because like
I've been to some like really fancy
looking coffee shops in Tokyo where it's
like the outside looks pristine like you
you'd think it's been there for like
hundreds of years and it's just like the
guy's just like professional about it
all and then you pay [__] you know 15
bucks for a cup of coffee and I'm like
this is just dirt water like I I got
really annoyed one time because I went
to one that was kind of like similar
yeah and it was like a again it was all
minimalist concrete and they had he had
an espresso machine there and I was like
okay let's go yeah and so I asked for a
coffee and I'm like can I have a can I
have a coffee and so if I
he just whips out like a pour over kit
and starts pouring over it I'm like dude
right behind me is that that machine
that's just for looks yeah yeah I'm like
dude I I thought it was going to be
espresso I wanted to Espresso such a
first world
such a first world problem but I was
just like so sad I was like no did you
ever uh one one like very common thing
with uh anyone who like goes to Japan
for the first time and lives there for a
period is uh the vending machine coffees
were you ever on that or
we dabbled in the boss a little bit Yeah
boss man
yeah I mean what was the one I really
liked the one that had like the the milk
in it
um rainbow one it would not oh that one
was good too yeah
um but it was like uh it looks like
creamy caramelly color on the outside
crazy how many variations there are
coffee yeah um and a lot of them are
very very sweet but like again I was in
the winter as well and it was like oh
yeah coming out hot so it's like yeah I
do like the the stabbing ones from the
combini the cartons yeah oh yeah
non-sweetened ones or they just call it
espresso even though it has milk yeah
right yeah those are good sometimes in
the winter I would not even like drink
the coffee I would just go to a vending
machine and just buy the whole coffee
and uh and just use it as a hand warmer
yeah yeah I remember when we went
camping once uh we went camping like in
like near Mount Fuji I was [__]
freezing yeah uh and uh we didn't have
any hand warmers so what I did is just I
went to the vending machine [__]
brought like six coffees and just like
dipped my coat in like all like I'm like
dipped uh put all the coffees like in my
coat and just slept with like a blanket
of like Boss Coffee yeah
make sure I didn't freeze that night
yeah you got it all man you got it all
so what do you uh what do you think is
like what do you think is the future
like the next like two three years for
yourself oh that's crazy that was a good
transition yeah I'm like what's your
coffee though what were you doing what
are we doing what's the five year plan
so I reckon here's the plan right okay I
got like the next six months that's best
I give you yeah because yeah I never was
thinking six months ahead at a time
um six months so next couple months do
some traveling enjoy life
yeah come to Japan as well yeah yeah oh
yeah Late July August so this is a
little after that but yeah we'll keep
we'll keep it going
um yeah just gonna see a lot of my
friends overseas they got a couple bucks
Stags and weddings going on so she's
gonna enjoy that come back Studio's
ready
grind like I'm gonna hit so I've hit
like a couple hard grinds in my career
so like starting off in Minecraft like
growing
biggest grind going
um you know how they have that thing
where it's like you know you can pick
work friends and then like family or
something and it's like pick two there's
no rest it's like work family and rush I
think that one's the one too is it that
one [__] I don't know anyway well the
thing was I picked work and then I
picked work again so it doesn't matter
which is that's just YouTubers yeah
that's that's it right but that was like
yeah first four years was biggest grind
ever took a little bit of break yeah
Pokemon go came out big grind fortnite
came out massive like four year long
grind yeah yeah I've tapered off last
year
um and I'm gonna come back I'm gonna hit
one last grind
the last grind that lasts like 10 years
or something you know it's like okay
this is the last Pride season final
grind part one
Tune In Tune in Final Boss uh in your
career have have you had a point where
you're like this is the last year this
is the last grind and I'm gonna chill
well I think even this is like kind of
very bold as [__] to say this is the
last grand at the age of 28. you're
gonna grind again yeah
yeah it does sound cooler uh but I think
that's like the last grind before like
you start looking at like the more
serious what's the next 10 years looking
like well you know you got to have like
oh I didn't you don't have to right but
like in my head I would like to we know
one day have a you know a wife and kids
yeah you know I don't think you can do
that with that level of grind so I think
this is the season finale of grime
before the serious era okay so yeah but
I I feel like there's a fact you know as
as a married man here guys I guess I
guess I guess
yeah yeah I'm married do you have kids
though no I don't yes I feel like that's
the big okay that is yeah I feel like
that's the biggest right now I guess
both me and my wife are grinding yeah
love that yeah yeah yeah
um so I feel like the big turning point
is when kids come and but but like I
feel you know even though you have kids
even though you get married or something
I feel like there's a fallacy to be like
I have to like give up this part of my
life oh you know because I feel like
there is like you know there's been
YouTubers who have had kids and built
families and not made content around it
like you know like a like a toxic kind
of way you know
um so I feel like there is a way to
adjust your lifestyle to I guess grow up
a bit no definitely yeah yeah definitely
but like this level grind had done oh no
like the date the daily uploads the
[__] working every day 16 hours
that's that's gonna stop yeah yeah no
100 so yeah definitely looking to to not
do that again and even then like with
this one I'm coming back on it's like
I'm definitely looking to Outsource a
lot more of team and like trying to
build they're spending this this two
months to build that team yeah how many
people are you working with right now
between myself and power
um and contractors including like
players I'd say I think we're at like
30.
gotta make some fortnite videos yeah
yeah but that way but this is the thing
with the orgs right like there's just so
many people that yeah that's where it
comes out of and I'm like well I think
we're doing well like outside of myself
we're not profitable yet but we're like
very close when do you think you'll be
probably not bleeding money is yeah no
I'm not I hate losing money yeah me too
me too yeah how long do you think you'll
need before you get profitable I reckon
if I'm not profitable next year
that would be amazing like we're close
like I think like our investment in this
studio office is the I think if we
didn't do that I think we actually would
be profitable okay so it's like a
reinvestment okay okay so we're like
we're like we're we're close okay all
right yeah awesome no we'll do thank you
so much for coming on the show yeah for
telling us all about it and uh yeah just
kidding us a bit on the fortnite and
it's uh it's not that overrated
it's a little bit it's not nice but uh
yeah would you like to check out Lachlan
stuff then uh obviously left it in the
description below so make sure to check
it out hey look at all these patrons
though yeah look at them see all these
patrons on screen right now there's so
many yeah
who do you think is a fortnight player
out of these guys
uh this guy
he's like [__] how do you know I was
like [__] is that anything you want to
shout out yourself uh no but I mean hey
if you guys could to get behind power
whenever you see us playing any games we
very much appreciate it we are The
Underdogs
three new fans yeah yeah no I appreciate
it boys forget a bit of Aussie pride in
there that's it that's it and even if
you're not Aussie and you just want to
support the Aussie boys get behind us on
the next land and uh yeah make sure to
stay tuned for the final
season's coming on yeah uh Hey if you
like to support the show then go to our
patreon patreon.com trash taste also
follow us on Twitter send us your memes
on the subreddit and if you hate that
face listen to us on Spotify and uh yeah
thank you very much man see you guys
next week cheers
[Music]
thank you